TPMP s'est rendu dans les coulisses de
Mister France on a croisé un candidat
qui avait un petit message pour un
chroniqueur Gilberta je suis désolé mais
tu es chez
on a aussi croisé le plus narcissique
des candidats il fait toutes ces
interviews en slip toi tu définirais
comment je me définirais comme quelqu'un
de drôle complètement toujours à côté de
la plaque surtout à côté de la plaque en
fait un candidat qui a tout pour lui
donc ou pas on peut avoir une petite
blague là comme ça une petite blague
comme ça alors c'est une blonde qui
marche dans un parc comme ça et puis BIM
elle croise une peau de banane et
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait oh merde je vais
encore tomber
ah Cyril on a aussi croisé l'un de vos
ex Cyril coucou mon lapin
c'est pas c'est un truc entre vous ça
reste entre nous et apparemment il est à
quelques lacunes en culture générale qui
chante les lacs du Connemara alors là
aucune idée on a aussi croisé le futur
vainqueur qui était un peu stressé toi
ça va toujours toi c'est bon
et enfin on a aussi vu Mister France
2021 qui nous a offert une belle darka
oh c'est pas forcément que le physique
c'est pour moi surtout l'éloquence moi
j'aimerais sauver le monde voilà
décidément il est partout celui Boyard
comment ça va alors Mister français là
Lisandre van Mulders
franchement comment ça va tu es heureux
c'est normal
tu es Mister France tu es content moi je
suis déjà arrivé je suis content tu es
content c'est la première fois que tu te
présenter
oui c'est la première fois tu as
ressenti quoi quand on t'a dit que tu
étais Mister France un sentiment de
fierté mais j'y croyais pas vraiment au
début tu croyais pas au début il y avait
pas de ouais
est-ce que tu te considères comme un
comme un beau gosse
bah forcément ce concours je pensais pas
que j'étais moche mais c'est
pas possible
tu vois je me présenterai pas
et donc toi tu t'es dit ouais tu
chantais que tu avais une chance quand
il y ait d'année mais en fait c'est pas
forcément que je me suis dit que j'avais
une chance mais c'est surtout que je me
suis dit que c'était une expérience
parce que de base je suis plutôt
quelqu'un de renfermé et du coup je
voulais m'ouvrir un
peu ouais à la vie quoi et là donc ça
t'a fait du bien qu'est-ce qu'on gagne
en Mister France bah j'ai gagné une
belle montre
je peux clairement sur leboncoin
frérot ça c'est vraiment mon ami oui et
tu as une belle montre tu vois je peux
te je peux te l'envoyer ça là et donc
oui aussi plusieurs costumes j'ai gagné
des produits de beauté j'ai gagné aussi
plusieurs
à 22 ans c'était beaucoup mieux tu es
beaucoup mieux en vrai c'est trop votre
façon
celui à qui tu parles c'est Castaldi
est-ce que alors là c'est que ça va être
quoi ton année donc toi tu faisais quoi
dans la vie en fait alors moi dans la
vie je suis coach sportif mais aussi
moniteur plongée
ce titre j'aimerais bien soutenir ma
cause qui m'est cher donc
l'environnement
parce que c'est important quand même
tu sais je veux dire un monde qui
respire c'est un monde qui vit non je te
montre
donc là pendant toute cette année c'est
quoi l'année de parce que l'année de
Miss France on la connaît
[Musique]
ici tu vois toi c'est quoi c'est pareil
tu vas aller dans les foires dans la
saucisse tout ça
c'est vrai question
tu as fait quoi là donc ça va j'ai
participé différents plateaux TV
est longue c'est une journée aujourd'hui
donc ce matin je suis passé à France
Bleu j'ai fait aussi des radios
excuse-moi elle est
je fais des interviews
tu vas faire quoi en fait du coup comme
je vous ai dit je vais soutenir ma cause
parce que tu étais c'est comme Miss
France c'est-à-dire tu pars parce que
Miss France en fait c'est un tourbillon
quand tu viens d'être élu et tu vas être
la couronne ça y est tu pars en voiture
et puis là ça y est tu es parti donc là
c'est Paris
ouais ça mais ça va s'arrêter demain ou
ça continue
généralement quand on entend le discours
des Miss elle rêve après de faire
peut-être de la télé de de faire des
choses dans le vieux visuel du cinéma de
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que toi
t'inscrivant tu t'es dit que tu pouvais
faire après est-ce que tu as un rêve
pour l'après te servir de ça comme un
tremplin
c'est vrai que j'ai plus ou moins un
rêve ça serait de rentrer en agence de
mannequin et puis pouvoir me développer
dans ce milieu là et tu penses pas que
ça
va c'est une possibilité mais en fait
moi je suis assez ouvert et je suis pas
figé sur un milieu précis et c'est pour
ça que si ça m'arrive tant mieux mais si
ça m'arrive pas à ton travail c'est ça
en fait c'est comme gagner le Mister
France pour moi c'était pas un objectif
c'est ça
on va discuter on va continuer à
discuter avec toi merci en tout cas
franchement merci d'être là l'histoire
et on a il y avait la présidente de la
cérémonie cité Nathalie Marquay
exactement et on a la pauvreté pour lui
montrer des photos des chroniqueurs
histoire de savoir s'ils pouvaient
devenir Mister France un jour
petit indice c'est pas près d'arriver
si oui ou non il pourrait être élu
Mister France ok on m'a envoyé des
photos Gilles Verdez
alors
désolé mon Gilles
mettez
avec cette coupe là ça va pas le faire
non mais sinon en temps normal
[Rires]
il a ce petit truc où il ose donc oui il
peut être élu ok bon la star alors
qu'est-ce qu'on en pense
et ben on voit qu'il fait du sport là
maintenant super bravo
alors il y a également chez Mr France il
y a les discours des candidats comme
chez Miss France toi tu avais préparé
ton discours ou pas j'avais un peu
préparé mais je voulais pas trop le
préparer pour que ça sorte plus
naturellement c'est ce qu'il faut faire
tu as raison le naturel ça paye toujours
tu vois non mais c'est vrai je pense que
c'est vrai que tu as fait la différence
aussi
je suis bien content d'être avec vous ce
soir et pour voir représenter mon île la
Corse
c'est vrai que je ne suis pas parfait et
vous pourrez pas meilleur sur ses
qualités là mais je suis quelqu'un qui
cherche au quotidien à devenir une
meilleure personne
je suis quelqu'un plutôt de timide de
réserver mais je suis aussi honnête
naturelle et joyeux
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que c'est mieux voilà mais
juste je voulais vous demander
l'élection Miss France on dit toujours
que les filles elles sont un peu toutes
sous le même moule grandes Chine et
lancées jeunes est-ce que vous il y a
une diversité est-ce qu'il y a un Ronda
un plus petit
on peut on peut retrouver chez tous les
candidats en physique qui est totalement
différent parce que vous pourrez
regarder Mister Calédonie ou même
moi-même
[Rires]
je suis un peu fatigué
on a aussi croisé Sylvie Sylvie c'est un
peu la maman de tous les candidats celle
qui devait les gérer dans toute la
soirée sauf qu'elle a passé la soirée à
être vénère c'est un peu la Gilles
Verdez au féminin on a la cérémonie on a
fait la rencontre de Sylvie Sylvie qui a
passé la soirée à de vénère et ça a
commencé dès le début à 21h10
[Applaudissements]
21h30 de personne n'était encore calé du
coup elle a commencé à s'agiter la
Sylvie
à 22h la pression était au plus haut
pour Sylvie elle était à deux doigts de
craquer
22h30 c'est la débandade pour Sylvie
plus personne la respecte
[Musique]
23h soit 10 minutes avant la fin de la
cérémonie sans nez trop pour Sylvie elle
craque
[Musique]
du coup on a décidé d'aller la voir pour
prendre la température on voit énervée
depuis tout à l'heure
il commence à fatiguer c'est vrai qu'ils
avaient quelques trous de mémoire et
alors qu'on la croyait enfin calmer les
candidats lui ont coupé la parole du
coup elle a pété un plomb allez vous
êtes chaud ou pas vous êtes très
simple
on a montré aussi une photo de Benjamin
Castaldi nos publics dans la salle cette
fois-ci écoutez bien les commentaires
honnêtement je dois pas honnêtement il
va manquer un petit peu de physique je
pense
et toi peut-être de taille aussi
il est passé grand pour faire le
concours
j'espère qu'il va bien le prendre vous
pensez qu'il pourrait être le Mister
France non non pourquoi
il a des seins en plus
[Applaudissements]
c'était une ancienne photo alors il y a
eu un truc aussi il y a Mister Auvergne
Mr Robert qui dit que c'était pipi
regardez on va voir vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez Mr Robert j'ai
vite compris que je n'avais pas les
mêmes chances que certains autres
candidats j'ai vu des membres du jury de
présélection donner des conseils à viser
discrètement à certains candidats en ce
qui me concerne je me suis très
rapidement rendu compte durant cette
semaine de préparation que mon profil
correspondait pas forcément à ce qui
recherche pour le futur Mister France je
représente l'Auvergne même si j'habite
plus ils ont encore une image très
arriéré de notre région et préfère
mettre en avant des régions qui sont
selon plus sexy il souhaite que le
candidat bénéficie d'un énorme soutien
au niveau des réseaux sociaux pour que
le concours en lui-même gagne en
visibilité et si le candidat a la
possibilité de venir avec quelques
partenaires ou quelques sponsors qui
prennent à sa charge c'est frais
d'habillement mais aussi de déplacement
c'est toujours mieux alors qu'est-ce que
tu en penses au licence que c'est
totalement faux parce que d'un point de
vue des réseaux sociaux moi je n'étais
pas très développé et puis je le suis
encore avant avant mon élection j'avais
6 ans d'abonnés maintenant 600 abonnés
et maintenant je suis à 3000 donc on
n'est pas non plus avec une grosse
notoriété ils sont en train de déconner
ils sont en train de décoller mon ami
oui tu es en couple ou tu es un chameau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une très bonne question mais
moi je dirais qu'il y a un juste milieu
je suis célibataire et je suis loin
d'être un Charo
[Rires]
que ce soit bon
esciente
sexy mettez un peu d'argent dans la
cérémonie ce sera un carton
moi je le ferai moi je le ferai oui
qu'est-ce que tu veux le prochaine
question est-ce que tu es proche ton
courage ou est-ce qu'ils ont trouvé ça
ringard que tu te présentes alors mes
proches mon totalement encouragé
alors j'ai pas de parole précise à vous
donner mais du fait qu'ils soient tous
présents là bah c'est pour moi c'était
une forme de soutien et puis de les voir
très heureux réunis moi ça m'a suffi
[Musique]
ou pas du tout non je suis bah pour
l'instant je suis pas payé mais je sais
que sur certaines représentations je
sais ça en fait parce que parfois on va
avoir Mister France dans un événement
pas ou si je te vois la barre mitzvah de
mon fils c'est combien
ça en fait tu fais des événements
en fait le fait d'être miss ça va te
rapporter de l'argent parce que tu vas
faire des événements en fait c'est ça
mais d'un côté le fait qu'on soit plus
modeste que chez les mistes d'un point
de vue financier et ben ça nous permet
d'avoir le côté compétitif qui est moins
imposant et du coup bah avoir plus un
côté fraternel durant notre
plus tard après Mister France Inter bah
du coup bah si tu me le diras mais pour
l'instant je suis fixé sur rien du tout
et c'est pour ça c'est pendant un an là
tu es Mister France Mister France Mister
France c'est ça donc tu tu tu dois
garder ton écharpe partout même aux
toilettes
et le fait de faire les missions ça se
trouve ils vont il va avoir plein de
demandes bien sûr France Bleu hier qui
vote en fait pour élire Mister France
bah en fait ça peut être tout le monde
ça peut être vous mais moi c'est le
public en fait que ça simplement on peut
envoyer des votes par sms ou même pas
par Internet voilà donc ça peut être
monsieur tout le monde d'accord et il y
avait un jury donc c'est ça oui il y
avait qui dans le jury il y avait
Nathalie Marquez Pernaut et puis il y
avait aussi Céline un ancien
Mister France donc
on l'a
[Rires]
je connais leur tête mais je connais pas
leur noms c'est pareil pour moi c'est
une dernière question peut-être on voit
les les Miss France défilés en monsieur
je trouve que le terme est un peu
vulgaire mais on a décidé avec un
maillot relativement court pardon on a
défilé effectivement avec un maillot qui
était relativement
tout à coup de pied au cul
[Applaudissements]